we are a little over two weeks away from
the primary elections here in nevada and
starting today early voting is taking
place all across the valley madison
kimbrough joins us live from one of
those sites near spring mountain in
cimarron with the details tonight
madison
long-term sites like the one right here
at desert breeze park have opened today
through june 10 along with several
short-term pop-up sites around town
north las vegas residents also able to
vote early starting today they could
submit their ballots for city mayor city
council wards one and three and
municipal court judge departments one
and two while here at desert breeze
we've seen some people come in and out
with papers in hand and here's what
clark county registrar joe gloria had to
say about making sure every vote counts
i think what's important for us is to
demonstrate to all voters that there's
integrity in our process if anybody's
concerned about elections we ask you to
go to the source
secretary of state is a great source of
information they've got lots of
information on their website our website
www.clarkcountynb.gov forward slash vote
as for henderson residents they can vote
early in person starting may 31st at
henderson city hall through june 9th and
that's from 7 30 a.m to 5 30 p.m for
those who prefer to vote from home
election officials have mailed out
mail-in ballots those you can drop off
at any early voting location like the
one we're at today for a full review of
candidates and voting location sites we
have a full list up on our website
reporting near spring mountain and
cimarron madison kimbrough live local
now